lyon du conseil de défense sanitaire qui
s'est tenue ce matin sous l'autorité du
président de la république nous venons
ce soir avec olivier ferrand partager
avec vous un point de situation sur
l'évolution de la cinquième vague qui
frappe notre pays comme tous nos voisins
européens et vous annoncer les mesures
de vigilance qu'elle appelle à l'
approche des fêtes de fin d'année le
virus le virus circule vite dans notre
pays avec près de cinquante mille cas
quotidiens ces derniers jours nous
sommes à des niveaux supérieurs à ce que
nous avions connu lors des précédentes
vagues le virus circule dans tous les
territoires et dans toutes les
catégories de la population
nos hôpitaux commencent à monter en
pression alors même que les équipes sont
très fortement éprouvée par près de deux
années de lutte contre la copie de cette
situation nous appel à la lucidité et à
la vigilance sans céder pour autant à je
ne sais quel affolement car si le nombre
de cas est à nouveau très élevé la
situation n'est pas la même qu'il ya un
an les français se sont massivement
vacciner c'est le cas de 52 millions
d'entre nous et cela a changé la donne
sans la vaccination nos hôpitaux
seraient déjà à des niveaux de
saturation équivalent à ce que nous
avions connu lors de la première vague
on en est loin et des mesures de
confinement aurait certainement déjà été
prises comme d'autres pays européens ont
dû s'y résoudre ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et l'objectif est
précisément que cela ne soit pas le cas
non plus demain il ya pour cela deux
conditions
la première c'est de conserver notre
bouclier vaccinale et même de
l'amplifier et de le renforcer car avec
le recul des derniers mois nous savons
que si le vaccin limite les risques de
contamination et protège très bien
contre les formes graves
il perd en efficacité avec le temps on
voit aujourd'hui dans nos chiffres qu
être vaccinés n'exclut pas d'attraper le
virus et donc de le diffuser on constate
aussi que passer cinq à six - le risque
d'être hospitalisés se remettent à
progresser notamment chez les personnes
âgées et fragiles d'où l'importance du
rappel vaccinal que nous avons ouvert
depuis huit jours à toute la population
de 18 ans et plus ce rappel non
seulement il maintient la protection
initiale mais il la booste
considérablement deux chiffres une
personne de 60 ans aura une protection
quatre fois plus forte après son rappel
qu'avant sans risque d'être hospitalisé
sera non pas 12 fois mais près de 20
fois moins élevé que la personne non
vaccinés
les français l'ont compris ils sont au
rendez vous nous vaccinons plus d'un
demi million de personnes chaque jour
des millions de françaises et de
français ont déjà fait leur rappelle
avec la mobilisation des centres et des
professionnels de ville 15 millions de
personnes supplémentaires pourront avoir
leur appel d'ici début janvier c'est
considérable olivier ferrand vous fera
un point sur les initiatives prises pour
augmenter encore le rythme ouvrir de
nouveaux centres et proposer plus de
créneaux de rendez-vous ou même pour
certains publics prioritaires des
créneaux sans rendez vous dans cette
campagne de vaccination nous devons
veiller à ce que les personnes de 65 ans
et plus c'est à dire les plus à risque
accède prioritairement à ce rappel nous
avons ainsi pris la décision que ces
personnes pourront dorénavant obtenir
leur rappelle y compris sans rendez vous
quel que soit le centre dans lequel
elles se rendent ce combat pour la
troisième dose ne doit pas nous faire
oublier celui pour la primo
vaccination près de 90 % de nos
concitoyens éligibles sont aujourd'hui
vacciner c'est un niveau qui nous place
devant la plupart de nos voisins mais
nous ne pouvons pas nous résoudre à ce
résultat si élevé soit il je souhaite
adresser à nouveau un message solennel à
nos concitoyens qui ne se sont pas
encore engagés dans la vaccination se
faire vacciner est un acte de protection
pour soi et pour les autres qui est
aujourd'hui hospitalisé en réanimation
ce centre est largement des personnes
non vaccinées elles peuvent parfois être
jeune et ne pas avoir de facteurs de
risques et que distel aux soignants qui
les prennent en charge si j'avais su si
jamais il est rassurant d'ailleurs de
constater que certains changent d'avis
entre 20 et 30 mille français le font
chaque jour il faut continuer car c'est
le coeur de la bataille
aujourd'hui avec le delta demain
peut-être avec le nouveau variant
omicron donc olivier véran vous dira ce
que nous savons et ce que nous ne savons
pas ou pas encore mais si le maintien de
notre bouclier vaccinale est une
condition indispensable
il ne suffira pas pour endiguer cette
cinquième vague d'ici les fêtes de fin
d'année permettre à nos hôpitaux de
tenir le choc dans les prochaines
semaines que nous disent les projections
de l'institut pasteur et du disque en
complément de la vaccination nous devons
ralentir le niveau de diffusion du virus
qui circulent dans toute la population
elles nous disent qu'en baissant
seulement de 10 % le taux de
transmission du virus l'hôpital pourrait
sortir de la zone de danger l'heure
n'est donc pas à des mesures de jauge de
couvre feu ou de confinement ce serait
disproportionné
en revanche les circonstances exigent un
effort individuel et collectif pour que
chacun limite les occasions les plus à
risque de se contaminer nous allons
prendre à cet effet quelques mesures
simples la première porte sur l'école
nous allons hausser au niveau 3 le
protocole sanitaire sa lippe
s'appliquant aux écoles primaires la
transmission du virus on le voit c'est
en effet fortement accéléré chez les
enfants de moins de 12 ans c'est logique
car ces catégories d'âge ne peuvent pas
encore être vaccinés et sont aussi
beaucoup plus dépisté compte tenu des
protocoles appliquée en milieu scolaire
notre priorité est notre boussole depuis
le début de la crise restent et
resteront de préserver l'éducation de
nos enfants c'est dans cet objectif que
nous avons déjà renforcé les mesures
barrières au sein des écoles avec
notamment le port du masque dans les
classes pour les enfants du primaire
nous allons demander un effort
complémentaire jusqu'aux vacances à
compter de jeudi prochain le port du
masque sera également requis dans les
cours de récréation et les sports
collectifs avec contacts seront
restreints à partir de lundi prochain
des conditions de restauration seront
aménagés en lien avec les élus locaux
pour limiter le plus possible les
brassages nous maintiendrons notre
politique de dépistage systématique de
tous les élèves
s'il ya un cas positif dans la classe et
de fermeture de la classe au bout de
trois cas positifs
pour ses enfants de 5 à 11 ans la
perspective de pouvoir accéder à la
vaccination est maintenant proche un
premier avis de la haute autorité de
santé laurent possible pour les 360
mille enfants en situation de surpoids
ou atteints de pathologies à risque
cela commencera dès le 15 décembre sous
réserve des avis et des instances
scientifiques et du conseil national
d'éthique que nous attendons dans les
prochaines semaines nous projetons de
pouvoir l'ouvrir à tous les enfants sur
la base
évidemment du volontariat si possible
d'ici la fin de l'année olivier ferrand
vous en présentera les modalités dans un
instant
la deuxième mesure porte sur l'extension
du télétravail beaucoup d'entreprises un
site d'ores et déjà leurs salariés à
télétravailler davantage dans le cadre
des accords qu'elles ont conclu au titre
du dialogue social c'est la bonne
méthode il faut que sur l'ensemble du
territoire toutes les entreprises qui le
peuvent et ne le font pas encore
mobilise le télétravail la cible doit
être deux à trois jours de télétravail
par semaine sous réserve bien sûr des
contraintes liées à l'organisation du
travail et de la situation des salariés
pour la fonction publique de l'état nous
autoriserons jusqu'à trois jours nous
comptons sur la pleine mobilisation des
entreprises nous ferons le point d'ici
une semaine pour mesurer l'évolution des
pratiques et si cela ne fonctionnait pas
par la voie de la recommandation ce qui
est notre choix nous serions amenés à
passer par celle d'une obligation la
troisième mesure porte sur tous les
événements festifs et conviviaux dans
les sphères professionnelles et privées
on voit bien où les risques de
contamination sont les plus élevés c'est
quand on se réunit dans des moments de
convivialité où l'on mange on boit un
verre on est debout à l'intérieur
proches les uns des autres sans masque
évidemment ce sont dans les entreprises
les pots de départ les séminaires les
les moments festifs de fin d'année ça
peut être à la maison un grand dîner
entre amis une pendaison de crémaillère
et c'est mon message est très simple
jusqu'aux fêtes de fin d'année on lève
le pied on arrête on se protège et on
protège ainsi notre capacité à profiter
de noël beaucoup ont commencé
spontanément à le faire dans un esprit
de responsabilité cette consigne doit
être passé par tous il faut maintenant
la généraliser y compris dans la sphère
privée qui relève de l'esprit de
responsabilité de chacun des règles
claires seront donc édictées pour tout
ce qui concerne le milieu professionnel
y compris pour les cérémonies de voeux
de début d'année et qui devront se faire
dans le respect strict des gestes
barrières mais aussi dans les
équipements municipaux comme les salles
des fêtes pour ce qui concerne les
manifestations et événements extérieurs
comme les marchés de noël les protocoles
devront évoluer sous le contrôle des
préfets pour que les conditions de
consommation de produits alimentaires
soient strictement encadrées et réservée
à des zones soumises au contrôle du pass
sanitaires le pass annie terre est un
outil d'incitation à la vaccination et
de protection face au virus que nous
avons été parmi les premiers à déployer
à l'europe nous l'avons renforcé depuis
cet été en l'élargissant à de nombreux
lieux en limitant désormais les tests
accepté à 24 heures et annie intégrant
dans les prochaines semaines la dose de
rappel ce qui renforcera d'autant son
efficacité pour passer cette cinquième
vague il est indispensable de contrôler
plus systématiquement est
scrupuleusement le pass c'est la
responsabilité des gérants
d'établissements recevant du public des
restaurants les bars les salles de
spectacle ou encore les transporteurs et
c'est moins le cas je le constate depuis
quelques semaines bien sûr nous
renforcerons les contrôles des forces de
police mais la clé cela ne doit pas être
simplement la peur du gendarme
mais la peur du virus et de ses
conséquences sur nos vies si nous savons
être vigilant et responsable pendant ces
trois prochaines semaines si nous
respectons ses consignes si nous
continuons à nous faire vacciner nous
passerons la vague enfin et c'est la
seule exception que nous ferons à notre
principe de ne pas restreindre
d'activité nous fermerons les
discothèques pendant les quatre
prochaines semaines cette mesure
s'appliquera à compter de vendredi
prochain et jusqu'au début janvier nous
le faisons parce que
le virus circule beaucoup chez les
jeunes même vacciner parce que le port
du masque est extrêmement difficile dans
ces établissements ne le faisons aussi
par cohérence avec le message général de
prudence et aussi comme le font beaucoup
de pays voisins
nous le ferons un accompagnant
économiquement les entreprises
concernées nous l'avons toujours fait et
nous devons le faire autant que cela
sera nécessaire c'est vrai évidemment
des discothèques dont je viens de parler
mais aussi des secteurs de
l'événementiel ou encore des traiteurs
qui subiront les effets de nos mesures
j'ai demandé au ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire d'engager dès demain les
concertations sur les conditions de cet
accompagnement qui devra s'ajuster à la
situation de chaque entreprise
je veux finir enfin à rappelant une
évidence mais qui est fondamental le
respect des gestes barrières ces gestes
nous les connaissons bien mais avant que
nous avons eu tous tendance à baisser la
garde ces derniers mois à mesure que la
situation s'améliorait j'appelle donc
chacune et chacun à respecter
strictement
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
lieux publics à l'intérieur mais aussi
dans les lieux extérieurs où il y à
beaucoup de monde je rappelle aussi à
chacun l'importance d'ouvrir les
fenêtres 10 minutes toutes les heures à
chaque fois que cela est possible
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
concitoyens nous avons les moyens de
passer cette nouvelle vague à nous
d'être responsable à nous de lever le
pied sur ce qui est à risque à nous de
nous faire vacciner dans les bons délais
à nous de rester vigilants face aux
nouveaux risques à nous surtout de nous
montrer solidaire vis-à-vis des
soignants qui sont à nouveau sous
pression et que nous devons soutenir et
remercier pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait
et font encore aujourd'hui pour protéger
nos vies avec ses effort proportionné
j'ai la conviction que nous sortirons de
cette cinquième vague comme nous avons
réussi à le faire
pour les précédentes je cède la parole à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé olivier ferrand
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs quelques éléments
effectivement complémentaires vous
l'avez dit monsieur le premier ministre
la cinquième vague continue de déferler
sur tout le territoire national un taux
d'incidence supérieur à 400 pour cent
mille habitants ça veut dire déjà une
circulation du virus qui est supérieur
au niveau du pic atteint lors de la
troisième vague cette cinquième vague
elle frappe toutes les régions tous les
départements et nous constatons
d'ailleurs qu'elle est encore plus forte
dans les territoires de la nation au
sein desquels la couverture vaccinale
est la moins élevée ce qui montre s'il
était nécessaire la corrélation entre la
vaccination et la protection cette vague
est donc d'ores et déjà plus haute que
la troisième vague que nous avons connu
un élément que nous que nous pouvons
observer c'est que il ya encore quelques
jours la l'augmentation de la
circulation du virus faisait que le
nombre de diagnostics augmenté d'environ
60% par semaine désormais depuis
quelques jours l'augmentation est de
l'ordre de 40 % environ par semaine ce
qui reste beaucoup mais ce qui montre
que les efforts individuels et
collectifs que vous avez déjà initié
cette reprise générale ce retour
gestes-barrières ses attentions du
quotidien que nous portons au travail en
faisant attention à éviter les l'epo ou
les moments de convivialité sans masque
dans la sphère familiale dans les
transports bref le retour des gestes
barrières et du port du masque plus
systématique ainsi que la couverture
vaccinale de rappel un demi million de
français reçoit un rappel de vaccination
par jour ces éléments nous permettent de
voir déjà peut-être un premier effet de
freinage mais le virus circule encore
vite ils circulent trop et le nombre de
cas continue d'augmenter
surtout cette cinquième vague n'est pas
qu'économique elle est évidemment aussi
sanitaire et vous l'avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre si la vaccination
complète diminue très fortement le
risque des formes de faire des formes
graves quand on commence à atteindre un
grand nombre un nombre élevé de malades
forcément on commence à avoir aussi des
cas graves à l'hôpital 2200 de plus de
2200 patients sont actuellement dans les
services de soins critiques de nos
hôpitaux en raison d'une forme grave de
co vide c'est un nouveau patient qui
rentrent en réanimation dans notre pays
toutes les dix minutes il ya plus de
vingt ans de plus de 2000 plus de douze
mille pardons malades qui sont
actuellement hospitalisés dans nos
hôpitaux avec un rythme d'admission de
presse qu'un malade chaque minute dans
notre pays je dis cela avec une pensée
un soutien très fort pour l'ensemble de
la communauté des soignants qui en
médecine de ville ou dans les hôpitaux
se bat à nouveau continuellement contre
l'afflux de malades et qui voit cette
vague montée avec une inquiétude qu'on
peut comprendre et qui attendent de nous
quand responsabilités nous puissions au
quotidien faire encore plus attention
pour augmenter encore l'effet de
freinage sur la circulation du virus
vous avez parlé des modèles pasteur qui
montre bien que nous pouvons encore nous
avons encore notre destin entre nos
mains grâce à la vaccination de rappel
et au respect des gestes barrières où
elle va demander monsieur le premier
ministre de revenir rapidement sur le
variant omicron pour vous dire que s'il
ya plus de 400 cas qui sont confirmés en
europe à ce stade on considère qu'il ya
sans doute plusieurs milliers de cas qui
sont en circulation et qui sont tant en
passe d'être diagnostiqués en france le
séquençage très intensif que nous
réalisons sur tous les tests positifs
suspect nous a permis d'identifier 25
cas positifs de ce variant omicron 21
sont des cas importés c'est à dire que
ce sont des personnes qui se sont
contaminées essentiellement dans les
pays d'afrique australe où ce variant
est apparu pour quatre cas c'est en
revanche probablement eu ce qu'on
appelle une contamination autochtone
c'est-à-dire une première transmission
interhumaine sur le sol français
évidemment nous agissons nous continuons
de le faire avec une grande rigueur une
grande attention c'est le fameux contact
racing renforcée et les mesures
d'isolement renforcer avec un objectif
freiner freiner freiner la diffusion de
ce variant omicron qui n'est pas en
cause dans la cinquième vague mais nous
ne voulons pas connaître de vagues dans
la vague quelques éléments que nous
savons à ce stade mais ce sont encore
des éléments très préliminaire je vous
demande de le tenir compte de ces
informations avec beaucoup beaucoup de
précautions nous en saurons plus dans
quelques jours il apparaît que ce
variant à l'évidence est plus contagieux
voire fortement plus contagieux que le
variant delta qui lui-même est déjà très
contagieux par rapport aux variants
précédent des études montrent première
étude qui montre qu'en afrique du sud
aussi bien qu en angleterre le virus
pourrait doubler jusqu à tous les trois
à cinq jours ce qui ferait une vitesse
de circulation de ce variant plus
importante encore que la variante lta il
n'y a aucun aucun élément clinique qui
nous permettent de considérer que ce
variant soit plus dangereux pour les
humains que le variant delta ce qui
serait évidemment une nouvelle
rassurante de ce point de vue là sur
l'impact de ce variant sur l'efficacité
du vaccin cet impact reste à démontrer
il ne change rien la stratégie ni en
france ni dans un an ni dans aucun pays
au monde et aucune recommandation
internationale ne va dans le sens de
modifier la stratégie de rappel vaccinal
c'est important aussi de le signaler
l'om est ce nous fait part de sa
vigilance extrême et le centre européen
des maladies transmissibles considère
que ce variant pourrait représenter la
majorité des contaminations par locaux
vides en europe d'ici à quelques mois
c'est pourquoi vraiment nous faisons
tout pour en freiner la diffusion
quelques éléments complémentaires sur la
vaccination monsieur le premier ministre
si 6,5 millions de rendez-vous de rappel
ont été pris depuis le jeudi 25 novembre
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
créneaux de rendez vous sont ouverts
chaque jour dans les 1300 centre parce
que nous avons rouvert 200 centres
supplémentaires en deux semaines et si
elle est très nombreux professionnels de
santé libéraux qui vaccinent ils sont
soixante mille à disposer de vaccins les
pharmaciens les médecins les infirmiers
notamment à domicile les kinés ainsi que
les sages-femmes cette campagne de
rappel suis donc un rythme extrêmement
forts qui nous place parmi les pays les
plus actifs de la campagne de rappel
d'europe et vous l'avez souligné nous
mettons d'autres mesures pour prioriser
l'accès des personnes les plus fragiles
si vous avez plus de 65 ans et ça
rendez-vous dans un centre il ya
également un numéro coup de fil de
téléphone qui peut vous permettre
d'avoir un accès prioritaire aux vaccins
de la même manière d'ailleurs si vous
n'avez jamais été vacciné et que vous
dit allez je me suis décidée je suis
convaincu je vais me protéger je vais
protéger les autres vous pouvez vous
présenter dans n'importe quel centre de
vaccination sans rendez-vous qui
s'occupera de vous protéger contre le
coc vide enfin la vaccination des
enfants des 5 à 11 ans vous l'avez dit
nous disposons de tous les feux verts
des autorités sanitaires et même de
recommandations des autorités sanitaires
pour ouvrir sans tarder la vaccination
pour les 5 à 11 ans qui sont atteints de
maladies chroniques qui les expose à des
risques de faire des formes graves
les enfants qui souffrent d'obésité
d'anomalies cardiaques respiratoires de
diabète peuvent les parents peuvent
évidemment contacter leur médecin leur
pédiatre s'ils ont un doute pour savoir
si leur enfant fait partie de cette
catégorie d'enfants dits à risque
environ 350 mille enfants sont concernés
la première livraison des vaccins files
heures avec une dilution adapté pour les
enfants sera faite le 13 décembre de
notre pays et sous 48 heures nous
souhaitons commencer à pouvoir offrir ce
vaccin aux enfants concernés par
ailleurs et sous réserve de la
validation finale par les autorités
sanitaires nous organisons toute la
logistique avec les centres et avec la
médecine de ville pour pouvoir le moment
venu commencer sans délai à vacciner les
enfants les autres enfants ceux qui ne
sont pas atteints de fragilité c'est à
dire environ six millions d'enfants âgés
de 5 à 11 ans en pratique cela pourrait
commencer aux alentours du 20 décembre
pour ce qui concerne les centres de
vaccination du 27 décembre pour ce qui
concerne la médecine de ville et les
pharmacies avec les mêmes réseaux que
pour les adultes mais je mets encore une
réserve nous avons un avis favorable du
comité d'orientation pour la stratégie
vaccinale du professeur fischer qui est
parvenu cet après midi nous devons
encore enregistré deux avis favorables
important celui de la haute autorité de
santé et celui du conseil consultatif
national d'éthique nous organisons toute
la logistique pour être prêt et ne pas
perdre la moindre journée pour ouvrir
cette vaccination aux enfants si nous
avons les feux verts et si d'aventuré
nous devions enregistrer des éléments
complémentaires de la part de ces
autorités sanitaires au moins nous
aurions tout préparé pour que les choses
démarrent sans délai dans notre pays
voilà monsieur le premier ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre donc comme
à l'habitude nous apprendre quelques
questions si vous voulez bien bonsoir
monsieur le premier ministre vont soir
monsieur mise de la santé camille collin
pour tf1 et lci j'ai deux questions à
propos des fêtes de fin d'année
notamment ces mesures suffiront elles à
passer noël est-ce que vous excluez
d'ici là de remettre des jo dans les
bars et les restaurants ou d'étendre la
fermeture de certains lieux accueillant
du public au delà des discothèques et
puis deuxième question vous demander aux
français de limiter leurs rassemblements
festifs y compris dans la sphère privée
cela veut-il dire que vous recommander
comme vous l'avez fait l'an dernier un
dîner de noël ou un dîner du réveillon à
6 personnes maximum merci beaucoup
un pardon
pour bfm tv j'avais deux questions
également vous avez parlé des marchés de
noël et des contrôles qu'il faut exercer
sur ce type d'événement qu'en est il
pour les grands événements qui sont
organisés en extérieur je pense
notamment à la fête des lumières qui
doit démarrer à lyon d'ici deux jours
est ce qu'ils peuvent se tenir ou non et
puis peut-être une question plutôt pour
vous monsieur minier de la santé
beaucoup de personnes ont encore du mal
à trouver un rendez vous pour faire leur
dose de rappel est ce que vous envisagez
d'ouvrir de nouveaux créneaux de rouvrir
des centres de vaccination et si oui
quand merci allez une troisième question
réponse il y avait monsieur morel avait
vu ou là bas
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
ministre la santé 1 pourquoi attendre
encore plusieurs semaines les avis des
autorités sanitaires pour annoncer chez
les enfants éventuellement une
vaccination obligatoire alors que dans
l'ensemble des pays déjà elle se
pratique ou en tout cas elle semble
accepter ou acceptable vous avez
également est d'ailleurs demandé par les
soignants vous avez affirmé
effectivement votre soutien chez les
hospitaliers qui ont des difficultés
aujourd'hui et qui sont réquisitionnés
par des plombs blond et qui demande
effectivement à des mesures fortes en la
matière concernant simplement maintenant
le virus au micro c'est pas très clair
encore que vous avez été clair cela
étant on a le président du comité
scientifique américain monsieur fossiles
carf aussi qui a dit qu'effectivement
c'était inquiétant a aussi grave une
intervention de la responsable sud
africaine qu'est ce que l'on peut dire
est que dit notre comité scientifique et
vous même sur cette question là le
dernière question sur les congrès et
notamment plusieurs congrès médicaux qui
ont lieu qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
tous ces congrès est ce que vous prenez
là aussi des mesures de d'interdiction
de ces congrès merci commente olivier
merci je commençais le ministre
complétera
il ya plusieurs questions un peu commune
les congrès la fête des lumières les
événements festifs bon 1 1 ce qui est
dès aujourd'hui de qu'est-ce qu'on peut
anticiper puisque c'est bien ainsi que
j'ai convocation qu'est-ce qui est ici
aujourd'hui vous l'avez compris ce n'est
pas l'interdiction de ces événements ou
de sairgroup qu'est ce qui est dangereux
ou en tout cas qui permet une
circulation virale forte c'est lorsque
on enlève le masque pour boire ou manger
dans ces événements on est debout on
parle enfin vous voyez tout ça donc
notre décision qu'on prend c'est de dire
à fortiori si c'est à l'intérieur mais
je vais venir sur les l'extérieur aussi
et bien voilà vous vous faites
rassemblement un congrès il peut se
tenir par
l'exigence du pass s'il est applicable à
l' établissement recevant du public
concerné mais vous pourrez plus faire un
pot boire un coup manger à l'issue même
chose la fête des lumières ça m'a été
posée donc où les marchés noël il y en a
beaucoup
l'idée ce qu'ils ont demandé au préfet
s'est pas de les interdire
c'est l'endroit où on se regroupe pour
consommer pour boire là il faut des
règles extrêmement strictes
le pass si on peut isoler la zone
concernée et puis des règles de
distanciation visant à assurer le
maximum la sécurité bon et si c'est pas
possible les activités constants 1 parle
pas l'intégralité de la manifestation
pourront être interdits c'est du cas par
cas par le représentant de l'état
ça c'est pour la décision que j'annonce
ce soir s'agissant voyez je le dis aussi
parce que j'ai annoncée les cérémonies
de voeux on a voulu avertir un peu à
l'avant
on peut espérer que tout s'améliorera
d'ici le début d'année nous l'espérons
tous c'est d'ailleurs la raison même
pour lesquels nous intervenons ce soir
mais l'idée se dire on va pas à redire
l'organisation des civils mais par
contre elle se ponctue il ya souvent là
aussi par moments où les gens se
retrouvent après pour manger pour boire
manger la galette c'est ça nous
demanderons à ce que ça ne sont pas
possibles
l'idée encore une fois c'est guidé par
le fait que qu'est-ce qui permet vous le
savez tous la circulation accélérer la
transmission de virus c'est le moment où
on enlève son masque et où on est en
situation de contact devrait d'ailleurs
je le dis aussi finalement le même
fondement que la décision relative aux
discothèques et vous observerez
d'ailleurs si on fait du benchmark comme
on dit c'est à dire des comparaisons
avec les pays qui nous entourent que
c'est revient une mesure qui se détache
tous les pays ne sont pas exactement
dans la même situation non n'adopte pas
exactement les mêmes dispositions mais
c'est une mesure qui se détache et lien
la fermeture de ce type d'établissement
l'objectif c'est évidemment
que tout cela pour l'accélération de la
vaccination pour ces mesures qui avaient
déjà été annoncés par olivier ferrand je
dis non pas de la semaine dernière mais
de celle d'avant concours où j'allais
dire renforce le petit mouvement que
nous voyons de du ralentissement du r du
fameux air d'accord puisque on voit bien
que les projections qui sont à notre
disposition montrent que pour protéger
l'hôpital en particulier pour protéger
notre système de santé il faut continuer
à infléchir cette progression épidémique
justement madame dans l'objectif de ne
pas avoir ces tests elle est bien notre
objectif à prendre des mesures de
fermeture de confinement de georges en
fait tout ce que vous avez si des
peut-être pour les autres questions
monsieur ministre oui sur la question
d'abord de l'accès aux centres de
vaccination est au rendez vous
à ce stade au 30 décembre sept millions
de français ont pris un rendez vous
d'ici au 30 décembre pour une
vaccination de rappel si vous annoncez
premier ministre sait qu'au 30 décembre
plus de 15 millions de français ont reçu
un rappel ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir
un doublement du nombre de rendez vous
pris sur le mois de décembre
donc pas d'inquiétude et ces deux rendez
vous sont ouverts au fil de l'eau à
mesure que les centres s'organise 200
centres de plus un grand nombre de
centres qui ont des lignes de
vaccination supplémentaires et donc tout
cela plus la médecine de ville qui a
commandé plus de 4 millions de vaccins
la semaine dernière qui leur sont livrés
et qui participe pleinement à cette
campagne vaccinale et qu'ils en soient
vraiment remercier tout cela va nous
permettre de remplir l'objectif est que
chacun puisse avoir la validation de son
pass préserver dans la durée si dès lors
qu'il sera la démarche effectivement
d'aller recevoir son rappel de
vaccination n'ont pas d'inquiétude de ce
point de vue là nous avons les doses de
vaccins nous avons les centres et nous
avons les libéraux il faut juste un peu
de patience puisque effectivement
lorsque vous avez 500 600 milles créneau
qui s'ouvre tous les jours ça veut dire
que de temps en temps il faut retourner
prendre rendez-vous et si vous avez pris
un rendez vous au mois de mars parce que
vous ne trouviez pas avant avant la fin
du mois de décembre vous aurez trouvé en
toute logique un rendez vous beaucoup
plus tôt pour vous faire vacciner pour
pascal morel vous avez parlé vous avez
fait une allusion à la vaccination
obligatoire des enfants n'y a pas du
tout de vaccination obligatoire des
enfants ni en france ni ailleurs ni en
france ni ailleurs ce qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est la possibilité de
permettre aux parents qui le souhaitent
de vacciner leurs enfants âgés de 5 à 11
ans et donc je les dis nous avons besoin
d'avoir d'abord toute l'europe sera
livré avec les vaccins spécifiques à
compter du 13 décembre dans les centres
hospitaliers qu'on appelle les centres
pivot pourront être vaccinées sans délai
les enfants atteints de maladies
chroniques qui les expose à des risques
de forme grave nous allons pousser les
vaccins destinés aux enfants dans tous
les centres de vaccination et en
médecine de ville pour qu à compter des
vins puis du 27 décembre toute la
logistique soit opérationnel pour
vacciner les enfants dont les parents
encore une fois sont volontaires je
reprécise des choses et nous avons
besoin pour cela des dernières
validations des autorités scientifiques
mais on ne va pas attendre la validation
pour commencer la logistique on veut
aller au même rythme que l'ensemble de
nos voisins et ne pas perdre une journée
notamment profiter pourquoi pas des
vacances de noël pour commencer à
protéger les plus petits pour éviter des
fermetures de classes des fermetures
d'écoles avec le virus qui circule très
très fortement dans cette catégorie
d'âge le taux d'incidence et plus de 800
aujourd'hui chez les enfants qui sont
scolarisés donc ils sont à beaucoup ils
ont des risques beaucoup plus faible de
faire des formes graves même si à 80
enfants hospitalisés à laquelle je vous
parle dont 15 patients en réanimation
c'est très peu par rapport au nombre
d'enfants c'est toujours parce qu'on
parle d'enfants mais par contre on sait
que l'effet sur la contamination globale
sur la circulation du virus est un effet
avéré et donc protéger nos enfants c'est
aussi protéger ses parents ses
grands-parents
sur la question du variant vous avez
posé la question à l'orgie répondu
peut-être pas suffisamment clairement
dans mon exposé je le redis pour
l'épargnant mikron manifestement plus
contagieux manifestement pas plus
dangereux mais s'il est plus contagieux
même s'il n'est pas plus dangereux ça
veut dire que si on avait six se mettent
à circuler beaucoup on aurait des
contaminations plus importante encore
qu'avec les variants actuel ce qui veut
dire que proportionnellement en finirait
par avoir quand même beaucoup de formes
graves est ce qu'on ne veut pas donc on
freine ce variant on l'empêchent de
diffuser partout il apparaît sur le
territoire ont fait du contact racing on
isole ont fait des bulles on tient on
achète du temps on gagne du temps face à
ce variant on attend aussi des jours
meilleurs on attend aussi d'avoir où le
virus circulera moins facilement où les
conditions météo sont moins défavorable
à l'humain que les conditions hivernales
et on attend aussi ça nous permet aussi
d'avoir des informations complémentaires
sur le côté opérationnel des vaccins
donc une grande vigilance ça veut pas
dire ça veut pas dire qu'il faut céder à
la panique pas du tout c'est pas le
discours le discours c'est de partager
en transparence comme je l'aï toujours
fait les informations de la communauté
scientifique nationale et internationale
à mesure qu'elle nous revienne sur
monsieur premier je sais pas si j'ai
répondu à toutes les questions qui
étaient posées sur les avait répondu
tout à l'heure sur les questions de
jauge de fermeture de rp et de
l'établissement au moment du public sur
les mesures de freinage encore une fois
on est dans une dynamique aujourd'hui
qui nous laisse à penser que la
conjugaison de la vaccination de rappel
et du ressaisissement
durcissement des gestes barrières du
port du masque et des attentions que qui
sont portés les uns aux autres plus la
suppression des typos des moments où on
avait des risques de contamination qui
était plus important sas a déjà et
donner une impulsion favorable par
rapport à l'épidémie donc on souhaite
pousser notre avantage jusqu'au bout
passée cette vague épidémique sans avoir
besoin de mettre de faire poser des
contraintes sur l'ensemble des français
qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non vacciner
les maraudes de la fp confirmez-vous qu
aucune mesure de restriction
supplémentaire mais envisager pour les
stations de ski qui avait eu un noël
blanc mauvais sens du terme
l'an passé et pouvez vous aussi faire un
point sur les discussions qui je crois
ce jeu au niveau européen concernant
l'imposition de test pour voyager au
sein de l'union européenne
faudra-t-il voilà se faire tester pour
entrer en france en venant de l'union
européenne ou pour aller dans un pays de
l'union européenne je je réponds
peut-être olivier s'il peut pardon
s'il peut compléter
nous avions je crois sagement prévu un
protocole à étages pour les stations de
ski justement pour anticiper dans le
cadre d'une concertation approfondie
avec les gestionnaires et les
professionnels de la montagne
différentes hypothèses et et notamment
celle d'introduire le pass sanitaires
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls éléments
de ce protocole à partir d'un taux
d'incidence qui malheureusement franchit
donc réponses très claires à ce stade
nous pensons que ce protocole est valide
et qui permettra de faire face à la
situation les discussions peut-être
olivier at-il j'ai pas de d'éléments du
jour on pourra vous les fournir les
discussions au niveau européen sur la
sphère des tests se se poursuivent pour
essayer d'avoir une plusieurs moniz et
on voit bien que sinon si chacun agit
dans son coin l'efficacité de la mesure
sera moindre évidemment nous ne
manquerons pas de vous dire le résultat
de ses travaux à moins que tu es des
informations plus récentes non monsieur
juste monsieur le prémice peut-être un
élément de bon sens avec le virus
circule partout en europe n'a pas un
pays européen qui est épargné vous avez
en fait trois blocs européen le bloc à
l'est du rhin allemagne autriche dont on
a beaucoup parlé une vague extrêmement
élevé un plus importante en allemagne
que toutes les autres vagues et qui
semble avoir atteint un pic depuis
quelques jours semble avoir atteint il
faut toujours un peu de temps de délai
pour être sûr ce qui est plutôt bon
signe tant mieux pour eux et ça veut
dire que le virus mais c'est le virus
est monté à des taux très élevés mais du
coup le virus circule beaucoup donc
mettre en place des mesures de test
entre l'allemagne et la france alors que
le même virus circule dans des
proportions importantes vous serez
d'accord avec moi ne fait pas sens il ya
le bloc france
qui a démarré plus tard la vague parce
qu'un meilleur taux de couverture
vaccinale notamment et donc avec des
niveaux qui sont encore inférieures à la
circulation allende et puis vous avez
les pays du sud de l'europe c'est-à-dire
l'italie l'espagne et puis une la suisse
qui ont démarré plus tard avec des
conditions climatiques il fait plus
chaud et plus sec plus longtemps qu'en
france hélas et l'italie et l'espagne
aujourd'hui connaissent une ascension
épidémique avec la même allure que celle
que nous avons connue il ya environ deux
semaines donc il ya ce décalage qui fait
que le virus circule aussi donc on n'est
pas dans des situations qu'on a pu
connaître auparavant vous aviez un pays
qui était fortement touchée par une
vague épidémique et les autres étaient
épargnés cette cinquième vague elle elle
est européenne elle touche aussi
évidemment les anglais la seule la seule
réflexion à voir c'est si vous avez un
invariant quelque chose qui apparaît
dans un pays frontalier dans ce cas là
des mesures de protection peut faire
sens donc comme l'a dit premier ministre
travail de coordination européenne il se
fait toute façon en continu en fonction
de la situation épidémique propres à
chaque pays de l'union européenne merci
beaucoup mesdames et messieurs merci
bonsoir